you know what I understand why people  always going for the one percent all the  women one was for the one percent why  don't you just find a regular nine to  five person that's going to look after  you you can be his Queen why can't you  just do that why is everybody really  rushing I've got a man we don't go on  social media everyone know about social  media nine to five I've got around  property 32 years happy as Larry what is  the problem it's the old-fashioned it  can it works no Auntie let me clarify  when I meant one percent is not the one  percent of Attraction I mean the actual  people that are in charge of the things  that run the world the way that what I'm  trying to say is that it's always been  an umbrella we've lived under but the  different functioned underneath it so  why is it going to affect me I'll  explain why because as Sir Mr Andrew  King Tate said